Oh Harry Potter was there anything more
magical than the first time you went to
Hogwarts yeah we didn't think so
you're totally jealous that we never got
our Hogwarts letter but the good news is
that with a few craft supplies we can
DIY our own at the cog Ward's Halloween
party
take your Halloween party to the next
level with these movie themed party
ideas keep watching to find out how to
turn your house into Hogwarts stranger
things
this Netflix series is one of the
creepiest and most awesome shows out
there it's definitely scary so it makes
for the perfect Halloween party it's
easy to take an old sheet and paint the
alphabet on it for a backdrop add lights
and you're all set you can create the
upside down with black vinyl tablecloths
cut into squares
spray some foaming gap filler and cover
it up with brown and black spray paint
turn on some 80's music and have fun
this look was created by walkers
unplugged The Nightmare Before Christmas
the best thing about this movie is that
it's perfect for Halloween and Christmas
invite your friends over for a viewing
party but do this awesome tutorial to
greet them cover your front door in
black paper and make a big white moon
using a poster board use some black
netting to create the curved mountain
cut out pictures of Jack Skellington and
Sally and put them on top of the
mountain use some construction paper to
make jack-o'-lantern garland we love
this front door look brought to us by
Disney family these send ins change up
the normal Halloween theme and have a VK
party
today you can turn your house into the
Isle of the lost or are Adhan pretty
easily and all your friends can come as
their favorite vks make fairy godmothers
magic wand by rolling some paper tightly
add the pumpkins with some styrofoam
balls decorate with some spray-painted
VK signs you can also decorate some
wooden letters for each one of the core
form add some VK themed cupcakes and
you're all set we love this Halloween
look by Douglaston Elly and Michelle's
party planet villain party if the V K's
aren't scary enough for your Halloween
party throw a villain party everyone can
come as their favorite Disney villain
turn your bathroom mirror into the Evil
Queen's mirror with some poster board
and bathtub paint don't forget to serve
some poison kernel apples and make
Captain Hook's ring-toss for a fun game
all you need is some foam board and
cheap hooks from the costume store we
love these fun decorations from a
sleepover ideas and catch my party
it with the release of it to this
Halloween party will be super popular
with your friends make a scary penny
wise hand by covering a cardboard circle
with fabric stuff a white glove with
toilet paper and make a hand and glue it
on the circle add a dowel rod and attach
a red balloon put some red handprints on
tracing paper and place them on the wall
right you'll float two on the red
balloons we love this terrifying
Halloween look from DIY parties channel
frozen Halloween parties don't have to
be scary through a frozen party for your
friends have an Elsa costume contest and
do some frozen karaoke then make some
awesome themes treats flattened diet
marshmallows into rectangles and put on
dowels dip in caramel and frosting and
add some blue sprinkles you can also
make frozen rice treats by melting
marshmallows and mixing with rice cereal
these family vlogs sure knows how to
make some tasty Halloween treats
Milana if you're sad that summer is over
Emma wanna party is the perfect solution
make heart of two fede party favors by
painting crafts rocks green Tama Toa can
be made out of cardboard fashioned into
a circle glue some treasure on it and
spray paint the whole thing gold shiny
his legs can be made out of cardboard to
make the wanna sail with some
two-by-four pieces of wood and an old
sheet then paint the symbol on the sheet
and you're ready to see how far you'll
go thanks for showing us how it's done
Renae Horton the Grinch
some people just can't wait for
Christmas and it's never too early if
you're ready for the Christmas season
through a Grinch party here are some
great food ideas make Grinch fruit
skewers with green grapes banana slices
strawberries and a marshmallow Grinch
popcorn is super easy melt some butter
and marshmallows then add some green
food coloring pour this over popcorn and
add mini marshmallows and red M&Ms to
represent his heart thanks for giving us
your recipe chloe Lucchese AK horror
movies if your horror movie fan you'll
love these party treats you can make
which sticks inspired by
the Blair Witch Project arranged pretzel
sticks in this pattern and cover with
melting chocolate drizzle some peanut
butter on top Texas Chainsaw Massacre
fans will love these saw your family
fingers cover t6 with rare roast beef
for a creepy appetizer add a Jason mask
and movie posters for some super easy to
core we love these treats brought to us
by two geeks who eat Harry Potter throw
a magical Harry Potter party this
Halloween drink cover your front door
with a brick wall guests can walk
through use a stamp for a sponge and red
paint to cover a sheet then cut up the
middle for the entrance make your own
Great Hall with floating candles add
some hot glue to the tops of toilet
paper rolls to look like melting wax
paint them white and add battery tea
lights hang them up with clear fishing
wire thanks for the tips paper gel
design and living Lee what sort of
Halloween party are you throwing this
year let us know in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a big
thumbs up and click the subscribe button
for more great content see you soon
[Music]